[Music]
on this Wednesday night the most
contagious form of covid yet it probably
got crept already through our door what
doctors know about this new Omicron
sub-variant
a murdered Ontario police officer laid
to rest Greg died a hero
and he lived as an inspiration appointed
tributes for Constable Greg perchella
Canada's first national ribbon skirt day
I feel proud celebrating indigenous
women and traditions and the young girl
who inspired it
packing away the parka and breaking out
the shorts Europe's unusually warm
winter
and Unstoppable hockey for us it's to
life Ukrainian athletes powering forward
during the war
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight Sophie Louie good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin tonight with a growing concern
over a new sub-variant of Omicron its
scientific name is
xbb.1.5 but some have nicknamed it the
Kraken subvariant it's the latest
mutation of the highly contagious
Omicron wave that emerged just over a
year ago 21 cases have now been detected
here in Canada in our top story tonight
Mackenzie gray looks at where it's
already seeing rapid growth
it's a new year and there's a new
sub-variant the latest spin-off of
Omicron is
xbb.1.5 it's the most transmissible
coveted strain yet and it's come to
Canada we had I think five as of last
week so there'll probably be more we've
seen every variant that's out there
um so we know that it'll come here the
public health agency of Canada says
there's been 21 cases nationally but
with a lack of widespread testing
experts believe the numbers are likely
much higher it's probably crept already
through our door and has probably done
so within the last month right under our
noses uh without us being able to
adequately monitor survey or report on
it
the new sub-variant has been found in
Asia and Europe but it's in the U.S
where it's spreading most rapidly at the
beginning of December it made up just
1.3 percent of all coveted cases but by
the end of the month it was over 40
percent and climbing it's just a smarter
variant at infecting and breaking
through walls of immunity one thing
still unknown how severe the new strain
is we don't have any data on severity
yet or on the clinical picture but we
also do not have an indication that
severity has changed to stop the spread
of not only the new sub-variant but
other illnesses schools in U.S cities
like Philadelphia and Boston are
bringing back Mass mandates I've had
covet myself we've dealt he has a cough
now so we're we're dealing with it but
so far few Canadian School boards have
followed suit Hamilton Public Schools
re-implemented a mass mandate in
December but students are allowed to opt
out with parental approval it's
important to recognize that while covet
isn't going anywhere
the tools to protect it ourselves and to
create safer indoor environments are
also the same as well despite the
sub-variants prolific ability to spread
Public Health experts still say that the
combination of antibodies from prior
infections and high levels of
vaccination mean that the massive winter
coveted waves of the past won't be
replicated this year Sophie Mackenzie
gray in Ottawa tonight thanks Mackenzie
the World Health Organization is using
its first news conference of the year to
highlight the importance of new
life-saving antivirals in the fight
against covet 19. the first generic
version of an antiviral has received who
approval and the hope is increased
production will lead to better access
for lower and middle income countries
but there are still major inequities in
access to testing and vaccination and
the who director General warns the
threat of covid-19 persists
and ultimately covid-19 remains a
dangerous virus to our health economies
and societies overall
every week approximately 10 000 people
die of covet 19. that we are aware of
the true toll is likely much higher
tomorrow the who will hold a wider
briefing on the global covid-19
situation along with member states and
Chinese scientists as cases there surge
an Ontario Provincial police officer
killed in the line of duty last week was
laid to rest today
foreign
[Music]
s of officers and their families
gathered for a procession to pay their
final respects to Constable Greg
pershalla the 28 year old was killed in
a shooting Ambush while responding to a
call for a vehicle in a ditch today as
his hearse made its way through Berry
the cold blustery morning matched the
mood on the streets
things happen we don't know why and when
they happen but
they chose a career that they want to do
and we thank him for for it because
their society needs police
you know it's devolving into chaos so
it's good to have them to keep
everything straight
it was an emotional day as Mike relay
reports prashallah is being remembered
as so much more than just a police
officer
the Barry Ontario Arena was filled to
capacity you could hear a pin drop as
the colleagues of constable Greg per
Shala raise his casket to their
shoulders
before the bagpipers LED them in a
solemn end to the remarkable life of a
young man who decided at the age of five
he wanted to be a police officer
pershalla was a gifted athlete wrestling
competitively in University before
eventually joining the opp he set the
bar high in everything he did which his
brother Michael says wasn't always easy
to live up to through the example he set
he made you want to be a better person
he made you want to make your own life
better
December 27th was a big day for
prashallah for the first time he was
allowed to work alone he was responding
to what should have been a routine call
a vehicle was in the ditch just south of
Hamilton
when he approached he was shot and
killed he was just 28 years old losing
Greg This Way
on the same day he learned he passed his
probationary period
on the same day he would become the
officer he always dreamed of being
it's cruel beyond words
two people were arrested and charged
with first-degree murder after a short
man hunt one of the two 25 year old
Randall Mckenzie was out on bail for
assaulting an officer in 2021 leading an
outraged OPP commissioner to call
prashallah's death senseless and
preventable he's the fifth officer to be
killed in Canada while on duty since
mid-september
[Music]
we're left to wonder what could have
been for a promising career while a
close-knit and proudly polish family
struggles with the loss of a son and
brother Greg became one of my greatest
teachers
and I can't even imagine how much more I
could have learned
Greg died a hero
microlight Global News Toronto
in the U.S Capitol today it seems like
political deja vu but what's happening
has very real consequences one of the
three branches of the American
government is essentially offline right
now as there's a stalemate over electing
a new Speaker of the House drama and
dispute within the Republican party is
playing out in vote after vote
Washington bureau chief Jackson prosco
takes us through the turmoil it happened
again a speaker has not been elected and
again a speaker has not been elected and
again a speaker has not been elected as
the stalemate within the Republican
Party blocks leader Kevin McCarthy's
path to the speaker's chair for a second
straight day sir you do not have the
votes and it's time to withdraw
once again the house adjourned without a
decision a repeat of the day before a
speaker has not been elected when
McCarthy lost three other rounds of
voting a speaker has not been elected
the historic humiliation was delivered
by 20 far-right Republicans who've
denied McCarthy the 218 votes he needs
they refused to budge demanding their
party make fundamental changes do you
think that the American people support
the status quo yes or no McCarthy's
opponents are so entrenched they ignore
the pleas of former president Donald
Trump and the vast majority of
Republican members
if we continue down this road if we
continue
with the actions of yesterday and today
we stifle the will of the American
people the result is not just one party
dysfunction but government gridlock
that's not my
problems
without a speaker no member of the House
can be sworn in and no business can take
place yet it's no longer clear any
speaker will be able to conquer the Deep
divide within the newly elected
Republican majority
this now seems to be a complete test of
wills and there are Furious negotiations
underway behind the scenes to try and
end the impasse but it's just not clear
how that's going to happen and even if
Kevin McCarthy were to drop out of the
running it's not clear who a consensus
candidate might be one sense of just How
Deeply divided These two factions of the
Republican Party are is that one group
has now written to the group that
oversees administration of the Capitol
building to complain about the fact that
McCarthy actually moved his belongings
into the speaker's office over the
weekend without actually winning the job
Sophie they're essentially accusing him
of squatting at this point
fascinating all right thanks for that
Jackson prosco in Washington tonight
thanks Jackson The Mastermind behind a
huge U.S college admissions bribery
scheme has been sentenced to three and a
half years in prison Rick singer's
punishment is the longest handed down in
the Scandal that involves celebrities
prominent business people and parents
more than 50 people have been convicted
singer pleaded guilty nearly four years
ago to bribing exam administrators and
coaches to get undeserving students into
Elite schools he also helped officials
build a case against others through
secret recordings with wealthy parents
who paid big money to get their kids in
school
California declares a state of emergency
coming up the brutal Super Soaker
barreling toward the state plus feeling
the heat the record-breaking
temperatures warming up Europe
and distracted fighting why Moscow is
blaming its own troops for the deadliest
attack on Russian forces
Californians are bracing for the latest
powerful storm as another atmospheric
River hits the Golden State with heavy
winds and up to 20 centimeters of rain
forecast for some areas over the next
two days the state's Governor has now
declared a state of emergency ahead of
worsening conditions to strengthen
response and Recovery efforts in San
Francisco residents have already
hunkered down with sandbags and supplies
the U.S national weather service warns
it will be a brutal system that could
bring widespread flooding power outages
and likely loss of human life Europe
meanwhile is facing wild weather of its
own unusually high temperatures are
sweeping through the continents smashing
many records this week on New Year's Day
multiple countries recorded their
warmest January day ever that includes
Poland and the Czech Republic which both
reported temperatures hovering around 19
Celsius while Spain and France saw
temperatures around 25 degrees Redmond
Shannon has more on the implications of
this unseasonably warm weather
sarajevo's Olympic ski resort with
nothing to ski on
Spanish sunbathing on the 11th day of
Christmas these are the dog days of a
winter warm spell January temperature
records are not just being broken but
incinerated across Europe yeah it's like
nice weather for Viking but we know it's
like the planet is burning so these
January records come after a year when
England registered 40 degrees Celsius
for the first time ever in fact 2022 was
the hottest year in record here in the
UK in France and in Spain climate change
is making these extremes more frequent
and making heatwise more intense
Europe's Rising mercury has caused a
fall in demand for natural gas EU
storage levels are high after countries
stocked up in the wake of the invasion
of Ukraine it's easing immediate fears
over how Europe can wean itself off
Russian gas that trade did drop sharply
last year and then the nordstream one
pipeline was taken out by Apparent
sabotage also there are fears the
Kremlin could fully cut Supply at any
time it takes a while to completely
transition an energy
and uh to do that they're going to have
to keep working at the pace they are if
not accelerated my concern is that a
warmer winter which is giving some
some breathing space is going to lead to
a warmer summer
Professor Grant walk says Russia's
Invasion has spurred Europe to speed up
its transition away from fossil fuels in
the interim Europe is buying liquefied
natural gas from the U.S and Qatar as
this winter is far from over if there is
a shutdown of the pipelines by by Russia
that again could contribute to some to
some issues in terms of Supply
Europe's warmer weather may have just
delayed its energy headache until next
winter Redmond Shannon Global News
London
playing with pride ahead a Ukrainian
hockey team's journey to get back on the
ice
[Music]
popular Iranian actress Tarana aladusti
has been released from prison on bail
she was welcomed by friends with flowers
nearly three weeks after being jailed
for a supporting anti-government
protests aladusti had condemned what's
believed to be the first known execution
linked to the protests the actress is
among several Iranian celebrities who
criticized the regime's violent
Crackdown on dissent Nationwide protests
erupted last September after the death
of 22 year old Masa amini in police
custody Russia says its own troops are
to blame for a deadly Ukrainian rocket
attack early New Year's Day Russia
claims the unauthorized use of cell
phones led to the airstrike on housing
quarters in the occupied Donetsk region
the military says phone signals allowed
Ukrainian forces to pinpoint the
location of Russian Personnel the
Kremlin also raised the death toll to
89. Ukraine has suggested around 400
Russian soldiers soldiers were actually
killed in the attack
well ten months since Russia invaded and
Ukraine is proving its National Hockey
Teams won't be stopped by the war for
the last two weeks the men's under-25
team has been playing exhibition games
against Western Canadian universities
preparing for a big International
Tournament later this month focusing on
hockey while War rages back at home
hasn't been easy but as Heather urich's
West reports the Ukrainian team is
playing with more Pride than ever
after a year of so much stress and
heartache Ukraine's under-25 National
men's hockey team ended 2022 with a
little fun let's go Calgary I'm like oh
we're actually going to the NHL game
it's like the Dream came true
watching the Flames host Vancouver on
New Year's Eve was a rare treat for this
squad
but this Four City Canadian tour isn't
just about watching hockey they came to
play
it's a good feeling you know when you
come here it's cold and it feels like
hockey
no one on this ice
tit when the Russian
Adventure Ukraine's National Hockey
program went dark for weeks the war kept
every player off the ice but over time
came opportunities outside Ukraine to
get back to the game for 45 days I think
the senior team was preparing in Hungary
and on the 18 they had the camp in Czech
Republic
and in Switzerland
now the under 25 team is in Canada
playing a series of exhibition games
against University teams in Saskatoon
Calgary Edmonton and Winnipeg all in
preparation for the winter University
games in Lake Placid New York later this
month hockey for us is to life
and I think
it's just one
Just One Fund
for us right now because the war at home
is always on their mind Monday morning
the team awoke to news of this a Russian
missile destroying yet another of the
country's hockey arenas it was a home
ice rink for many of us for example
Andre played there for six years it's
why each player on this team wears the
blue and yellow with pride after a year
with so much destruction Against All
Odds they're keeping the spirit of
hockey in Ukraine alive Heather urich's
West Global News Calgary
indigenous Pride on display next
celebrating Canada's first national
ribbon skirt day
[Music]
indigenous communities in Canada marked
a milestone today on the path toward
reconciliation it was the first ever
National ribbon skirt day an opportunity
to celebrate an important symbol of
indigenous culture Toria Israeli
explains the significance of these
sacred skirts and introduces us to the
Saskatchewan girl who inspired this
special day
bold colors Rich patterns intricate
designs the Styles may vary but each
strand carries a special meaning I just
feel really happy when I wear my ribbon
skirt
twelve-year-old Isabella kulak and her
mother are especially Happy on the first
national ribbon skirt day a day Isabella
inspired now everybody could wear their
ribbon skirts with pride without feeling
ashamed she felt shame two years ago
when it was Formal Wear day at her
school in Southeastern Saskatchewan
Isabella wore a ribbon skirt to
celebrate her identity as a member of
Cody First Nation it's a sacred piece of
clothing representing resilience and
strength but a teaching assistant told
Isabella her ribbon skirt was not formal
enough they said it was inappropriate
so instead of uh turning this into a
negative we thought we turn into a
positive to educate the School Division
the school apologized to Isabella and
her family but a story resonated on line
and across the country eventually making
its way to the Senate Isabella I want to
tell you that there are Senators wearing
their ribbon skirts Manitoba Senator
Mary Jane mccallum's Bill declaring
January 4th the first national ribbon
skirt day received Royal Ascent last
month I still can't get over it it's
an overwhelming feeling super proud of
my little girl in a statement prime
minister Justin Trudeau said every year
from now on January 4th will be an
opportunity for us all to learn more
about and to celebrate indigenous
cultures Traditions histories and
contributions to this diverse country
the federal government formally
recognized orange shirt day in 2021 as a
way to highlight indigenous culture and
honor residential school survivors
indigenous leaders believe ribbon skirt
day is another sign children are leading
the way I feel very humbled knowing that
you know our children are speaking up
I'm excited and
and I feel proud
pride and resilience woven into every
ribbon
tariya isri Global News
Ottawa
and that is global national for this
Wednesday night I'm Sophie Louie
tonight's your Canada is Edmonton where
this lovely New Year's greeting made of
ice took about a week to finish thanks
for watching tonight hope to see you
again tomorrow have a great night
[Music]